[Music]
Here We Go Again Sony have announced the
PlayStation Plus essential offerings for
the month of September 2023. three games
will be downloadable starting Tuesday
September 5th it's an interesting month
please do me a favor and throw me a like
to keep this series going and here we go
game number one is the Saints Row reboot
the rumors were indeed true an open
world action title in which we start our
own gang of Outlaws and plan to take
over all the other criminal
organizations in Santo Alesso one year
ago at launch Saints Row was packed with
bugs and glitches and that was reflected
in the Metacritic score which is 61
yikes since then though a great deal of
work has gone into fixing issues and
making this open world a playground of
Mayhem whether that's Wing suiting
around playing oversized Jenga or using
ridiculous weapons like the thrust
Buster honestly I could play with this
thing all day
every five minutes you'll be in a
firefight and the melee combat goes hand
in hand with with that with some really
inventive special moves on offer like
stuffing a grenade down someone's shots
and flinging enemies back where they
came from over 1 000 enhancements have
been made over the last 12 months
including two new city districts tons of
new missions two-story expansions and so
many Cosmetics it's impossible to see
them all Saints Row's story is the
weakest element for sure as the dialogue
and acting is honestly like a primary
school Nativity Play but without a doubt
playing in co-op with a friend papers
over the cracks plus there are some
12-person multiplayer Shenanigans too
don't expect too much from Saints Row
and you'll easily have enough content to
tide you over until Spider-Man 2
releases in October oh and you should
really check out the Character Creator
in this game the community have done a
pretty good job with some of these oh
next we have Black Desert traveler
Edition the open world MMORPG has been
here for years constantly updating and
growing over time and right now many
players who left are returning to play
again and with the solid core Story
complemented by numerous side quests in
a world that is begging to be explored
the experience begins with its best part
an in-depth Character Creator and then
we are simply left to our own devices
back in 2019 we had little to no
explanation of the mechanics and systems
of the world and we had to use Google I
do hope times have changed now Black
Desert is packed with combat but it
isn't all about that you'll be trading
fishing horse training cooking and
trying your hand at Alchemy too oh and
Black Desert has the same Metacritic
score as Saints Row 61 and finally
generation zero a first person shooter
set in an alternative Sweden in 1989.
here violent robots have taken over and
now it's your time to fight back and
take down everything from scouting
drones to robots bigger than a house gen
zero is not an arcade style shooter oh
no this is all about survival and the
Highlight is cooperative play online
with up to three friends you can
distract and attack all the Machinery in
Sweden coordination is the key General
zero has a review score of 45 out of 100
but many updates have been added since
then including Homestead building and
new Weaponry so will you try it so what
are you playing this month please sound
off in the comments below if you're
happy sad delighted or mad I'm adamaru
you're awesome I'll see you next time
[Music]